oh this is going to incriminate me
[Music]
my name is my name is dana
eldest daughters especially azada we
just there's a lot of expectations
it's always nerve-wracking to make a
mistake everything was just like your
siblings are going to be watching you
like you have to set a good example oh
be like
look at what rola's doing it stops
sometimes never have i ever
snuck out of the house
[Music]
leaving telling my parents beforehand
and not telling them
like right as i was leaving oh i've
definitely snuck out of the house
i have i was always so scared so i would
only go to the backyard
if you know like my friends were coming
over or whatever it was oh i have never
my curfew was 9 p.m if i was out at 901
pm
i would get question mark text from my
dad never have i ever
cursed at my parents
i did once i will never forget it i was
18.
i didn't have my own car so i wanted to
borrow my mom's car
and she for whatever reason said no so i
said
screw your car basically and i
definitely deserve
the response that i got looking back i
don't blame her
i've gotten very close but my mom loses
her mind if i just swear in front of her
so i can't even do that
i have never cursed at my parents
i have around them my brother would say
like
kara all the time which means in arabic
that was a lot for all of us
never have i ever parented my siblings
no i do that every day multiple times
and like my parents owe me for that and
they know that
my mom passed away five years ago and i
have taken on that role
in many ways i think i've definitely
tried
they are not receptive to that i think
that just
that's just my personality never have i
ever
lied to my parents about my location
no that happens often but it's for their
own sake like they would be worried when
they don't need to be
yes i have but it's not like it's not
like i was ever
out doing something crazy where i think
after i took the sats in high school
my friends and i all went out to get
ihop and there were guys there so i
didn't tell my parents i was at
ihop like it was it's always like the
littlest lies
living on campus i remember many times
my parents would call me and
you know i'd be getting ready to go out
with my friends but
they were under the impression that i
was getting ready to go to bed or i was
going to the library it's for their own
peace of mind
never have i ever taken the fall for my
siblings
no i've never taken the fall from my
sibling we're not that rebellious
yeah i've done that i have covered up
pretty big
situations my sister actually took off
a semester from school my dad thought
the entire time that she was in school
but the entire time
she was just working she wasn't doing
anything wrong but she didn't want to
break his heart and i
i helped her cover up for it and she had
every intention of going back and she
did
so you know we pulled it off he still
does not know
tuesday wow
never have i ever translated for my
parents
[Music]
i have never actually my parents have
like high education
they i never had to step in um
as like a translator for them as i know
like a lot of other eldest arab kids had
to
my mom learned english by watching
barney so by the time i was speaking
english
she was also speaking english and then
my dad had been in the states ten years
before that
we went here when i was three my parents
did not speak any english
i have very vivid memories at
seven eight maybe even younger on the
phone with my parents like
credit card companies or who you know
whoever they needed me to talk to
explaining that i was the translator and
the person on the other side was saying
oh how old are you
you know i tell them and they would get
so shocked i still translate
pretty often for my dad never have i
ever
had a finsta
oh i yes i have a fence though
oh i have a fenced stone i also have a
fenced eye
and i have like 30 people that are
trying to follow me and i just leave the
requests there
because i don't know why you think we're
on a level that i can like share my
finster with you
i'm a hijabi i'm going to be posting
photos without my hijab point
my sister used to follow my fenced off
but not anymore
filming drama let's call it
never have i ever gotten into a fight
for my family
i have gotten into a fight i was in
fifth grade
i think my brother was in kindergarten
it was on the playground
and i think my brother
had oh this is gonna incriminate me
my brother had like a lollipop or
something and this kid was bullying him
i think he was a first grader
and i went up to that kid and i saw him
he was like trying to take his lollipop
and i pushed him to the ground
because you don't mess with my little
brother yeah we really stand up for each
other when the time comes for it and i
definitely fight people all the time for
my family and for my parents and for my
siblings
loyalty is key i grew up in a very small
conservative town so
being the only arab family we
stood out and there are many times that
i can remember having to
fight people or you know verbally argue
with people over
calling my mom towel head or terrorist
or anything else because of her hijab
talk about your experiences
because nothing is going to change if we
don't
share the things that we've done that
might be taboo or
or you know weird or just not accepted
in our culture
so i think that's so important
especially for the younger generation
you're actually not your siblings
parents and really the person that
defines the relationships at home
are your parents as the adults in the
situation
there are still lines that you can draw
and you shouldn't feel guilty for that
like really really should not feel
guilty for it at all there were days
where i
literally thought my parents hated me
and now i look back and i was i'm like
they never hated me
but just the pressure they put on you as
a kid is
so immense but i would just say like
it's so hard when you're in that moment
to like think anything else
but you will become independent you will
live your own life
you'll have such a such a better
relationship with your parents too when
you grow up
[Music]
you